et cette année le thème de la nuit des
idées c'est être vivants alors pour ma
part en tant que femme en toute féminité
et bien je vais répondre à la question
restée vivante en tant que femme puisque
vous n'ignorez pas que de par le monde
ça devient parfois de plus en plus
difficile quand on est femme de rester
vivante par ailleurs j'avais publié il
ya quelques temps une anthologie sur le
thème des migrants de l'exil et c'est ce
qui s'appelle nourriture néons humaniste
et je vais également abordé ce thème
êtres vivants sur le mode être
survivants donc voilà rester vivante et
être survivants voilà ce sur quoi je
vais axer mon intervention est bien sûr
je ne serais pas tout seul nous
commençons à 18h et nous partons dans la
nuit des idées est jusqu'à ce que les
idées ce soit vraiment exprimé est bon
il ne s'agit pas pour moi de larmoyer
par exemple quand je me mets en avant ma
féminitude qui va au delà du féminisme
il s'agit pas de larmoyer mais de donner
de la voix voire d'élever la voix y
compris la voix des sans voix au féminin
pluriel pour qu'elle soit entendue c'est
toujours ce que j'essaye de faire et
donc je vous y convie l'entrée est libre